hey what's up my name is Samuel Leeds
and on this video I'm gonna explain to
you what a lease option agreement is
this is how I've bought properties using
zero money and it's how I've actually
created most of my wealth through
properties so what is a lease option
agreement it's really really really
simple a lease option agreement is when
you buy a property now so you buy it
today but you don't pay for it for some
time down the line which is agreed
between you and the seller that could be
three years five years seven years ten
years now
why is lease option agreement so genius
the reason is is because if you buy it
now but pay for it in ten years well on
average properties double in value every
ten years but by the time you come to
actually have to pay for it it's doubled
in value on top of that in the ten years
not only if you gain from all the
appreciation of the property but you've
also benefited from the monthly cash
flow because you buy it and become the
landlord as if you own it today
but don't pay for it for ten years so
it's absolutely incredible you might
think oh my goodness but I've got a bite
in ten years no you have an option not
the obligation to buy in ten years but
the seller has to sell it to you if you
insist
that's how options work now the reason I
say I was created most of my wealth
through Lease Option agreements is
because when I started I didn't have any
money I didn't I couldn't get a mortgage
so I couldn't buy a property there were
so many reasons why I was unable and
unqualified to buy a property and become
a landlord and I didn't have the money
some of the main reason but I got into a
property via Lease Option agreements not
only that but now today I'm cashing in
on all these properties that are now I'm
releasing my right to buy them with my
option and and and now I'm buying them
for 30 40 50 percent below market value
so that's what a lease option agreement
is who can do one
anyone you can be bankrupt and do a
lease option agreement these work in
England but they also work in most
countries globally as well so I know
people are doing these in the state how
do you find people to pass you their
property on a lease option agreement you
find motivated sellers and tired
landlords that just their properties are
burden to them but for you it's an asset
because you are a property investor on
the property investors crash course we
literally find live properties and
sellers for people who be suited to do a
lease option agreement but you won't
come because you're a loser probably
sounds harsh but only 1% of people that
watch these videos actually take action
so prove me wrong don't be a loser don't
be a [ __ ] to someone else working for a
job forever you can take yourself out
the game and say I've gotta go oh I
haven't got the money or oh no no no
just take action come and meet me at the
property investors crash course believe
me after meeting meet for two days you
have any friggin excuses because if you
can buy a house on a lease option
agreement with no money pretty much
anywhere in the world like serious so
you're watching this video for a reason
so in the description get yourself
booked on to the property investors
crash course by the way I'm not the only
person doing these option agreements I
just had a guy who was in the Daily Mail
yesterday his name's Ian Patterson he's
bought 18 properties 18 properties with
no money on a lease option agreement
he's now worth 2.8 million that's that
his property portfolio 2.8 million he's
left his job he's in the newspapers he's
one of many many many of my students
that are buying properties on lease
option agreements this way using 0 of
their own money so do the same get the
knowledge implement I look for to seeing
you on the next video thanks so much
peace out
you
[Music]